team biden is trying to solidify its
standing or even take the lead in a
number of midwestern states
the former vice president made stops in
wisconsin minnesota and
iowa on friday where he's been hammering
president trump over his handling of the
coronavirus
ed o'keefe is here in new york with the
latest ed good morning
good morning jeff today biden is
reuniting with an important sidekick
former president obama
will join him for events in flint and
detroit as democrats try to snatch back
michigan a state they lost four years
ago
but it was biden's stop in iowa on
friday that was perhaps most interesting
democrats are trying to turn the hawkeye
state from red to blue
with president trump defending states he
won on friday joe biden went on offense
in iowa
a state now in play after the president
won it easily in 2016.
folks we can do this there's nothing
beyond our capacity
it was a far cry from february when
biden lost badly in the iowa caucus
now he's within striking distance of
winning the hawkeye state as the
president's popularity is plunged with
coronavirus cases on the rise
the former vice president held a
socially distanced drive-in rally
here at the fairgrounds the iowa state
fair canceled for the first time
since world war ii and donald trump has
given up
biden also dueled with the president
next door minnesota where he leads by
nine with just three days to go
a longtime democratic state baidu was
asked why he needed to schedule a stop
there i don't take anything for granted
we're going to work for every single
vote up to the last minute
meanwhile attention is turning south to
texas the state considered battleground
territory for the first time in
generations amid a record surge of
voting
more than 9 million texans have voted
early that's more than the total number
of voters in the 2016 race
some polls show it could be close and
reliably red texas and that brought
kamala harris to the lone star state on
friday
you have power and at election time that
power will be through your vote but
there may be trouble brewing for biden
in florida amid reports that democrats
are failing to turn out supporters in
miami-dade county
an area where hillary clinton dominated
four years ago
even as she narrowly lost the state the
biden campaign says the pandemic kept
them from doing most traditional voter
outreach in florida
so other groups are stepping in like
faverna pierre
with the unite here labor union first we
started calling people for the phone
and by uh the first week of this
of this month we started knocking on
doors and to get people out there to
what we we're trying our best
and ed is back with us for more on the
state of the race ed you were just
focusing on florida a little bit we've
talked about a lot of states three days
to go in the campaign give us some idea
of where the campaigns
are going to be focusing yeah at this
point with fewer than 72 hours to go
it's not what they're saying it's where
they're going and if you look at the
next three days the state that's getting
the most attention
is pennsylvania as paula mentioned
earlier the president's holding four
events there
today tomorrow biden gives a speech in
philadelphia
and then on monday the entire biden
harris ticket the two candidates and
their spouses
are going to barnstorm the keystone
state running from end to end trying to
take back that state it's another one of
those big industrial states
the democrats know they need to win back
biden of course
emotionally invested in the state he was
born there when he was in the senate he
was often called pennsylvania's third
senator because he's from neighboring
delaware
and he has spent more time in that state
than any other believing
that he's the kind of democrat that can
win it back but the president
holding several rallies 14 over
three days in seven states pennsylvania
though getting the most attention from
both sides you said it right there is
there anything
that president trump or for that matter
president vice president joe biden can
say
in these remaining days that can
influence voters
well republicans would like the
president to keep focused on the economy
remember they got some encouraging news
late in the week
with the record gdp growth the best
quarterly growth rate since world war ii
as we're trying to claw
our way out of the pandemic recession
economists say probably not enough just
yet but certainly an encouraging sign
but of course the president doesn't
necessarily stay on message
uh you know talks about those minor
grievances that he has with all sorts of
people
and then made these interesting comments
suggesting that doctors are
profiting off the deaths of coronavirus
patients something that biden hit him
for yesterday
in his later stops for the for the biden
team it is basically all about the
pandemic raise concerns about the
president's management of it
vow to try to do a better job of
handling the crisis and getting the
economy back
on track we'll see whether the president
can stick to his message but he is
certainly going down
or going down to the wire we should say
in the final days here
doing what he does best holding those
rallies and bringing out his supporters
in hopes that they head to the polls by
tuesday at
tons of early voting which is a good
sign for democrats does this then now
come down to republican turnout on
election day
yeah so we have seen record early voting
which means that people are heeding the
warnings and the suggestions that
they should try to get this done sooner
than election day in the event that the
lines are too long
there are only about 20 states that give
us the partisan breakdown of who has
either cast a ballot by mail or in
person so far that does favor democrats
that matches the polling we've been
doing for months that suggested more
democrats than republicans would do it
early
but that doesn't mean that democrats are
going to win remember the only piece of
math that matters is
who won after all the votes have been
counted so we have to wait until
election day
when we do anticipate in many of the
biggest states at least that a lot of
republicans will show up as they
normally do
and the only poll that counts is
election day
ed thank you so much